[Music]
so welcome to session 21 of the
philosophers in the midst of History
this is a quarterly series that we do
here at the Frank Weinberg library and
so you know we talk about a ancient
philosopher the medieval philosopher
broadly speaking sometimes they're not
philosophers per se an early modern
philosopher and then in 19th or 20th
century philosopher and I'm it's kind of
funny when I you know we've done Plato
and Aristotle and epicurus and Epictetus
and Plutarch but we never did Socrates
we probably should have let off with him
because he's so important and so this
year when they're they're asking me who
do you want to do I was like well yeah
we we probably should have done him a
long time ago so we're finally filling
in that that bit of the picture he's
such an important figure in many
respects and I wanted to start off by by
talking about I'm actually going to cite
something from the Stanford encyclopedia
philosophy and ding on it a little bit
because I think it's a little silly what
they have to say so we'll start you know
with who who's the Socrates guy why is
he so important
um
there's a lot of contrasts he's he's one
of those people that
you know you look at the interpretations
of Socrates and they're all over the map
there's there's and they're they're at a
significant variance with each other so
there's a lot of people who over
confidently present a certain picture of
him exactly the way Socrates was and
then they reduce them to like one aspect
of what he was teaching or you know his
words or his actions or thoughts and
it's to some kind of imaginary figure
you could say that doesn't conform to
what we actually do know about Socrates
but listen to this wonderful starting
paragraph for the entry in the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy the
Philosopher's Socrates remains as he was
in his lifetime an enigma an inscrutable
individual who despite having written
nothing is considered one of the handful
of philosophers who forever changed how
philosophy itself was to be conceived
all her information about him is second
hand and most of it is vigorously
disputed but his trial and death at the
hands of the Athenian democracy has
nevertheless the founding myth of the
academic discipline of philosophy and
his influence has been felt far beyond
philosophy itself and in every age and
some of that is quite true you know he's
very influential you could talk about a
founding myth of philosophy maybe if he
wasn't executed he wouldn't be
considered as important it allowed him
to take a stand that would be
memorialized by two of his followers in
afan and and played on them looked to by
a whole bunch of other people as a model
but is he really an enigma I don't think
so I mean we do know a lot about the guy
despite the fact that it's second hand I
mean we could say the same thing about
so many other thinkers as well as we'll
we'll talk about in just a bit when we
get to the like what's historical about
this guy but I think first
um we want to situate him
in his history and this is why I created
a timeline for you that's got like
events that are particularly important
and pertinent to Socrates himself and
then what was going on in in Greece
particularly Athens as a whole at the
time and you notice that at the time
that Socrates is
um uh coming to be you know there's a
lot that's already happened the Persian
Wars have come to a conclusion uh with
the the vast Persian Empire being beaten
back by the you know Plucky Greece you
know we all know the the story about
that it was actually more from the
Persian perspective like a hiccup you
know they tried to invade Greece didn't
actually work
um they would continue to make inroads
you know corrupting various uh uh
political leaders in Greece using gold
and not really caring about what happens
in that Backwater over there quite so
much because they had an entire Empire
to run all right come on in
um and so Socrates is born you know in
Athens uh he's a citizen and actually
his friend Credo is born around the same
time in more or less the same deem or
you know little part of Athens and by
the time that he's born the this Delian
League has existed for about a decade
Ashley's the you know when we think
about the playwrights right you've got
echelis and then Sophocles and euripides
Ashley is the big granddaddy uh and we
were going to have Aristophanes in there
he's already started win his contests
and putting on his his uh
tragedies the Delian League is important
because
this you know after the the Persians
invade and they get beaten back the
Athenians and the others are like well
we need to make sure this doesn't happen
again so we're going to have a nice
Alliance uh we'll keep the money there
at delos and everyone will you know
contribute sort of like NATO or pick
whatever other uh Alliance you've got
and it it gets the ball rolling on
Athens becoming more and more powerful
more and more corrupt eventually
becoming viewed as the Tyrant City
but um it's not quite there yet and then
you know shortly after Socrates is born
we have kind of a changing of the guards
Sophocles defeats specialists in this
tragedy contest and then we start to see
things happening in Greece in in
Socrates childhood so some of the
members of The League are leaving the
league they're like this is kind of BS
we don't like this and then they're
being compelled to stay in it around the
same time
there's this contest that's happening in
Athens and you know we usually associate
Athens with democracy right that's the
the place where democracy began and all
that not entirely true I mean there were
Democratic like institutions in other
places and cultures but in in Greece
Athens gets viewed as like the central
place for that and there's this contest
between what we often call the oligarchs
and the Democrats and it's it's almost
better to say as some researchers do
conservatives who just wanted the
culture and the societies stay more or
less the same and then populist
Democrats who are trying to change the
structure and nature of athe and
sometimes with very good reason and so
there's two main characters early on
this guy kimon and the one who we
generally pay attention to Pericles and
Pericles is on the side of the people
and he you know succeeds in getting this
is very common Athens you don't like the
person who's opposing you get him
ostracized get him kicked out of the
city for 10 years or 20 years or
whatever whatever it's going to be and
so there's that going on and then we get
the first Peloponnesian War starting and
the Peloponnesian War we all learned in
history class is between two great
Powers Athens and Sparta it's actually a
lot more complicated there's all these
city states and you know Athens is in
charge of the Delian League and they're
the ones who are sort of running the
show and you know they try to install
democracies here and there Sparta is the
leader of the other states that don't
like Athenian Supremacy and you know
interestingly the Spartans were often
seen as liberators by other states that
we're trying to overthrow Athenian uh
hegemony you could say and so they you
know they start fighting and there's a a
war over Delphi one of the main
religious sites and for a little while
um they're able to as you see a little
bit later on
declare this 30 years peace this peace
treaty that's going to keep Greece from
falling apart
and by this time Socrates is a young man
and as a young Athenian citizen when
he's 18 years old he's presented to the
city or actually his deem his little
part of the city he gets a examination
you know basically to prove that he's
competent to be on a jury or Vote or
stuff like that it doesn't appear to
have been a very high bar to meet and
then he begins his two years of
compulsory military service which is
right there in Athens he doesn't have to
go anywhere as a matter of fact uh you
may or may not know this Socrates is a
real homebody the only time that he goes
anywhere is to fight
unlike a lot of other people in ancient
Greece especially Athenians who would
like go to Egypt you know or go over to
what's nowadays you know uh turkey Asia
Minor uh what part of the Persian Empire
at the time or travel to other cities ah
he just wants to stay at home he's he's
he's not interested in going anywhere
else and he starts to meet people who
are important only when they come to
Athens you know so for example
Parmenides and his student Zeno two
important ancient philosophers who don't
live in that area they actually live
over in Ionia they go to Athens because
there's games being held and so Socrates
you know manages to meet up with them
and and chat with them if the platonic
dialogue that we we have called the
Parmenides is actually truthful
and then we start to see
all this other stuff happening there's
other Wars taking place and gradually
Greece is getting to the point where a
major war is going to break out the the
vast Peloponnesian War that takes place
where Sparta has a real advantage in
military forces on on land but not not
quite so good at Naval stuff the
Athenians have a great Navy there's
other important cities involve Corinth
Argos in the peloponnese Thebes way up
North a number of other places uh that
that you know we mentioned here like
Megara
and Athens is you know viewed by a lot
of people at that time as the aggressor
and the Spartans as you know kind of
standing up for for the other Greek
city-states and they get into a number
of different fights and and battles and
and we see that Socrates starts to get
involved in some of these and there's
another guy really important
for the history who's also getting
involved besides Pericles who we've
already mentioned this guy also biades
alcibiotes is a younger leader he's
actually somebody who's connected with
Socrates
falls in love with Socrates at a certain
point it's kind of a what we call a
golden boy so you're a noble family Rich
super good looking
charismatic you know the kind of guy
who's gonna have all these advantages
and he's also a screw-up on a massive
scale right and Socrates is trying to
help him out with that you know giving
him some good advice it doesn't
completely stick
but you could say well you know how bad
would you have been without Socrates
maybe he would have been even worse
just like we could say like Seneca and
Nero or other people like that and so
Socrates actually gets involved in the
Peloponnesian War he fights at uh
potadaya
um and he um you know he and also biades
are assigned to put down a Revolt El
sobieties has a nice cush position
Socrates is just you know an ordinary
foot soldier Socrates actually saves
Elsa biades in this case Socrates is
kind of a badass when it comes to
fighting he he's tough he's he can put
up with all sorts of physical
obstacles that would fell other people
it doesn't seem to be affected by heat
or cold can drink as much as he wants
can go without you know food or water uh
he's he's a rough tough guy but he's
also a philosopher and so now we start
you know seeing these these battles
going on more and more and more and
Greece slides into this this massive
um
conflagration you could say and you
notice that there's like defeats that
that take place these are the battles
that Socrates is involved in he's there
at uh dellium
um he distinguishes himself in the
retreat which is you know when you would
have an ancient
um battle the losing side usually lost a
lot of its people as they were fleeing
because that's when you bring in the
Cavalry cut people down and stuff like
that so keeping order during the retreat
is incredibly important Socrates save
somebody else on this one xenophon
um among among others he's also in the
battle at uh amphipolis
and which is another Athenian defeat I
guess you know maybe Socrates is kind of
a bad luck charm to bring to battles or
something like that but you know he uh
he's doing his share and that's quite
important and what we start to see
happening as and this is kind of a you
know a good theme to bring up that maybe
has a broader significance
I mean think about this when things
don't when things are going well
usually people are there to take the
credit for it and you know make their
own agenda out of it
when things go badly what what usually
happens in a country or organization
you got to find people who are
responsible right and then kick them out
and stuff like that and so we see that
um
you know there there's uh a lot of
Athenian defeats as well as victories
and it's gonna affect not just Pericles
but also alcibiotes eventually we're
going to see it's probably gonna play a
factor in in uh how Socrates himself
dies later on now the El sobiities uh
you know we're not really this isn't
really about him but I should mention
you notice in the timeline he gets
around a lot he starts out working for
Athens
and he leads this disastrous
Sicilian Expedition the Athenians have
gotten a little bit too big for their
britches they're doing pretty good and
then they're like we should go and
Conquer
um uh you know some of the cities in in
Sicily particularly Syracuse they find a
pretext for that and Elsa bites is all
for this
and then something happens that kind of
prefigures Socrates own trial and death
there's all these statues called Herms
and they get damaged and you know these
are considered important they're
dedicated to the god of hairmase
so nobody's quite sure who did it uh
later on they find out that it wasn't
the people who got accused because they
start kind of like a Witch Hunt except
there's no witches instead it's people
that are going to be accused of impiety
a sebias this uh not taking the
religious
you know rituals beliefs
places seriously and El sobieties is one
of the people who's accused a number of
other people who are close to Socrates
as well and so also by 80s
um he's ready to start this big
Expedition with two other generals and
he's actually argued for making it even
bigger and bigger and bigger let's go
over there in full force and then
they're like yeah when you come back
you're going to stay on trial and maybe
it will kill you and he's like why don't
you try me right now so I don't have to
like go off on a Expedition and you know
waste my time fighting for you and come
back to get to get executed and they're
like no no you go you go off and do that
and then later they will actually try
him in absentia and he'll find that out
he'll be like well screw this you know
and he defects and he goes over to the
Spartans so he's going from you know
leading the Athenians to being an
advisor to their enemies
she doesn't stay there that long not
because he doesn't like Sparta but
because he gets himself in trouble and
then he defects to the Persians so now
he's really getting around quite a bit
he will get recalled to Athens later on
after Athens suffers well first they
lose in in Syracuse and that's a
disaster and then you know the Spartans
invade the Spartans actually
um you know allow the let's call them
the anti-democratic elements the you
know oligarchs to come to power and
um the uh
there's going to be you know like a
Uprising against them the Democrats will
bring El sobieties back to lead the Army
but he's kind of a broken guy he'll
actually be removed from from uh command
later on
um and as you see you know by 404 Athens
is exhausted they've been fighting for a
long time they blew a lot of their
resources on this Expedition a lot of
their allies have abandoned them allies
slash you know protectorates
um not not full allies you could say and
what we see end up happening is the 30
tyrants are installed in Athens by
Sparta and Socrates doesn't cooperate
with them you may know this famous story
from the Plato's apology they tell them
to go get this guy because he was very
popular back then go get this guy we'll
bring him back here and then we'll kill
him you know because he's he's a threat
to us and all four of the other people
that are told to go do this go and do it
Socrates just goes home he's not going
to cooperate with them and uh you know
he's kind of a principled character when
it when it comes to Justice and stuff
like that and so you know uh he would
have died if the 30 tyrants hadn't been
overthrown
um Athens will sort of rise up again
they'll leave the Peloponnesian League
led by Sparta and refound the Dalian
league and this is all leading up to
very close to Socrates death in 401
thucydides the guy who wrote the history
of the the um uh Peloponnesian War dies
leaving this account behind
xenophon leaves Athens at that time if
you're familiar with the account of the
10 000 also called the March up or the
anabasis he actually
um got hired along with a whole bunch of
other Greeks to be mercenaries in this
Persian Civil War that was taking place
by the time they get to where they're
supposed to be the war is over and
there's no money and now they're just
they're wondering what the hell do we do
here and the Persians invite the
commanders in for a dinner to discuss
things and Kill Them All
so it's all the junior commanders and
they March back to Greece over the next
several years taking a town along the
way fighting off Persian forces a really
compelling story which apparently
provides the basis if you've ever seen
the movie about New York gangs called
The Warriors that's supposed to be
roughly modeled on the uh the March back
of course it takes place in just what 24
hours rather than two years but so
xenophon is you know one of Socrates
students he he arrives back you know
about the same time that Socrates is
dying and you notice that uh Socrates in
399 very world famous event he's TR he's
put on trial for corrupting the youth at
impiety now other philosophers had been
accused of impiety before and they were
smart enough to get the hell out of town
you know Socrates he's not leaving
Athens and if you read the account of
his trial it kind of sounds like he
threw it he used it as an occasion to
make some some points that he wanted to
make and he's found guilty when they
they say well you have to propose your
penalty uh instead of like proposing a
fine he says well you know I'm such a
good guy for all of you you should give
me free meals for life in the puritanum
you know yeah I think I'm pronouncing
that right and um they they say
we're going to kill this guy and he he
would have died like the next day except
there's this special Expedition
celebrating the myth of Theseus has to
go off and come back and you can't kill
anybody because it would be ritually and
pure to do so while that's happening so
the poor the poor guy gets to hang
around for a while and this is where you
know Plato's dialogues come in
um you know we have this entire sequence
that many of you have probably read
where you've got the use of fro and then
the apology itself and then The Credo
where his friend Credo a childhood
friend is saying hey bribe the guards
let's get the hell out of here and
Socrates let's consider let's think this
through and he decides not to and then
we have this final dialogue one of uh
Plato's best called the Fado which is of
the day that Socrates
um he doesn't he's not actually executed
by somebody else he has to drink poison
so executing himself
um in accordance with the laws of his
City so I mean this is the this is the
historical background for the guy and
you know you might say well
how do we actually know any of this like
we know about the the Peloponnesian War
because the acidities wrote about it
we've got all sorts of other records
we really be sure that like Socrates had
his trial said this thing or had this
conversation with Gorgeous at calekly's
house at this time or that the Symposium
really worked the way that Plato says
that it that it did
and the answer is you know we can't be
100 sure but you know in a way we don't
need to so this leads to the next thing
I wanted to talk about
um and then maybe after this we'll do
like a little bit of q a break it up a
bit because I'm talking a lot at you so
we call this the socratic problem
and it's it's kind of a pseudo problem
um it's something that
you could say Has Two Faces there's the
scholarly Socratic problem with its own
history and books and articles and all
these people arguing with each other
sometimes you know getting quite heated
about stylometrics and philosophical
doctrines and then there's the question
that comes up anytime that I teach
um Plato with with undergraduates and
that's well how do we actually know
Socrates didn't write anything how do we
know that the guy that Plato is talking
about is the person Socrates and Plato's
not just like making stuff up and
attributing it to him you know because
we don't have a lot of other
corroborating sources so there's you
could say the scholarly Socratic problem
and then there's the common sensical
Socratic problem that any person could
could raise and the first thing I want
to point out is
people sometimes get a little bit too
demanding about this because we have
similar historical problems with many
other figures from Antiquity you know
some we can be a lot more sure about
others you know we don't we really don't
know much about it all
and this extends not just to ancient
Greece we can talk about the Quest for
the historical Jesus that is occupied so
many scholars since the 19th century on
Albert Schweitzer actually said that the
it's very much like looking down in a
well you see your own face at the bottom
so some people read Jesus as being like
a you know a cynic sage and other people
who see him as being a you know
revolutionary leader and others being
you know this or this or this right
what do we have to go on well some
gospels and then this guy Paul's letters
you know a book of Acts and a few other
non-canonical sources and that's
basically it you know when it comes to
the uh the Buddha I mean nothing's
written down until hundreds of years
after the guys died you know so there's
there's actually in in you know
religious studies there's a quest for
the historical Buddha there's a quest
for the historical Confucius same
problem didn't write anything down uh
and we can even say this about other
figures that are closer to us like
Epictetus the great stoic philosopher he
didn't write anything down I mean he did
we know that he wrote stuff for his
classes we just don't have any of it
instead we have a student of his who
wrote down these discourses and told us
some stuff about it but we don't know
how accurate you know it is maybe he put
his own ideas into epictetus's mouth so
who do we have for Socrates well we got
Plato we've got all these great platonic
dialogues some of which are clearly
Plato using Socrates or even other
people the elated stranger you know as
mouthpieces for his own philosophy
saying things that Socrates probably
didn't say right
but then a lot of dialogues were
probably as Socratic and then we've got
xenophon and xenophon is a lot less
flashy than than Plato there's not a lot
of metaphysics going on or you know
anything like that so a lot of people
assume that xenophon must be like the
the real deal and then what else do we
have we only have one other contemporary
source and it's a a playwright a
comedian
who basically just wants to say bad
stuff about Socrates right all the stuff
that was coming up at the trial and
Socrates brings it up at the trail he's
like
I've got all these old accusers one of
them is this guy over here who says that
I take the weaker argument make it look
good and talk about all sorts of things
in the heavens and I'm not that guy so
clearly we can't really rely on
Aristophanes as a source
um and so
one of the ways to handle this is to say
that well Plato made stuff up xenophon's
a historian you know we can trust him at
any place where Plato diverges from
xenophon it must be Plato making stuff
up
um and that's you know that's a solution
it's not a good one because xenophon
wasn't spending a hell of a lot of time
with Socrates like some of these other
people were he was off doing his own
thing and you know we can't be sure that
that xenophon is actually more accurate
there's other ways of looking at it one
of the guys who gets the ball rolling is
you might know a schleier mocker this
this great religious and philosophical
writer from the early 1800s in Germany
he he says there's a Socratic problem
he's got this this piece that he wrote
the worth of Socrates as a philosopher
and he thought that only two dialogues
were completely Socratic the apology and
The Credo so all the other early ones
nah it's Plato and Socrates mixed up
together
um
and so you know he he's not particularly
helpful there have been a couple main
ways of trying to figure this out one is
to do
um they call it stylometrics meaning
measurement of stylistic
uh features of the texts so you can say
well you know this word shows up or this
phrase shows up right in these texts so
they must be the earlier older texts
that are more reflective of Socrates
these are the newer ones you know
Plato's getting to be a better writers
time goes on
um
every time you come up with a theory
like that
it's pretty dicey you know because
there's often a lot of circularity
involved the other thing that you can do
is talk about arguments or doctrines
right so Plato
you know for example you know what are
some platonic doctrines the
um notion that there's forms right these
ideal Essences that exist out there God
only knows where and uh you know so for
example each of us is a human being a
material existing thing there's some
sort of Ideal human being out there that
we all participate in
okay that's probably not Socrates
Socrates was really interested in
definitions but he doesn't appear to
have believed in that sort of thing so
you can say well so the dialogues where
the forms are being mentioned those are
later those aren't Socratic those are
more platonic so we we you know we leave
aside the republic or the Fatal or
um you know the phaedrus or any of these
other ones where the forms are being
mentioned and then we look at the ones
where it's not being mentioned and we
say aha here's the real Socrates
now how do we know that those are you
know later dialogues and those are
earlier well because they mentioned the
forms so again we have a circularity
right none of these ways of I mean it
does seem like there has to be a early
middle late right with any author
but the criteria by which we do this
it's kind of kind of um
dubious right if we place too much on it
there was a recent article by Deborah
Nails who talked about four different
possible interpretations that we could
use one is we could say Socrates is the
the person who whose qualities exhibited
in Plato's writings are corroborated by
Aristophanes and xenophon
there's not much there if we do that
right or we could say Socrates is the
guy who claims to possess no wisdom but
still participates and exercises with
the aim of gaining understanding okay so
that's clearly something that he was
doing uh he does say at some point that
he doesn't possess wisdom he also shows
us that he does possess wisdom at other
points right so but we could use that
and say okay the apology The Credo the
lock case
um the lysius these early dialogues
where they they try to explore something
and don't make any real Headway that
would be that would be the Socrates
stuff we could also say that Socrates is
the individual named Socrates who
appears in Plato's earliest dialogues
totally circular to say that because
we're using that to Define what the
early dialogues are and then we could
say that the real Socrates is the one
who turns from a pre-socratic interest
in in nature to ethics
not really helpful either so none of
these criteria for the historical
Socrates turn out to be compelling to
everybody there's no consensus about
this except for the idea that yeah there
must be some early ones and then there's
some places where it's just Plato and
where do we draw the line well it's it's
tough to say so I I myself usually you
know when my students ask me about I'll
I'll go through some of that and then
I'll say let's just put it aside and let
let's talk about what were the actual
ideas being communicated in these texts
and that might be more helpful what what
did people make of Socrates right and so
I've talked at you quite a bit this
might be a good place to
you know answer any questions about this
stuff before we talk about the so-called
Socratic method and then talk about the
influence this guy had so any any
questions that you want to ask at this
point or confusions or
clarifications that you want or
otherwise I'm happy to keep going on in
a non-socratic way I'm not going to use
the Socratic method yeah oh
yeah so again this is something I often
tell my students about because we'll
talk about courage in class and I'll say
you know it's one thing to like shoot at
somebody in a fire fight 300 meters away
or you know calling an artillery strike
this was up close and personal you know
uh you if you were a Greek hoplite you
had this big long spear right and he had
a shield and then he had some sort of
Sword usually called it cephos and that
was like your absolute backup weapon
your spear was your main weapon and you
get together with all these other guys
and you know get into a formation and
then you just keep on jabbing you know
trying to get the other guy in the gut
sort of like what what Patton said you
know it's not your job to give your life
for your country it's your job to make
the other poor bastard do that for his
country right and so that's what they
would do there are all sorts of other
ways to fight they had you know archers
they had these these people that were
called peltus who had they were like
light infantry with shields and javelins
they'd come running up to you and throw
these javelins at you and then take off
Slingers you know
we actually have uh sometimes they'd
make the the slingshots out of lead
it's like a big ball of lead right and
they would write things on it like dexa
take that you know
I feel like we used to do that with
bombs and things and a sling will get
that ball moving really really fast then
you let it go and if it hits somebody in
the head yeah that'll kill them you know
so it was all sorts of really awful
bloody ways to disembowel carve people
up you know
it must have been just terrifying
to be involved in these battles you know
compared I mean I'm not denigrating the
fighting that takes place today it's you
know undergoing an artillery uh strike
is is pretty terrifying from what people
say but
um you know you had to you had to fight
like that and then you could get you
know infections afterwards
a lot of Battlefield
um uh wounds turned in turn septic and
really awful so does that answer your
question
yeah I mean it's not a great thing to
get involved in you know
not a lot I mean the three that we know
about they're big battles and he was on
the side that lost which is the scarier
side right so like I mentioned being if
you're going to retreat you gotta
Retreat and they talk about Socrates
um and being involved in the retreat and
like guarding against the um the Spartan
forces that are otherwise going to rush
at them and kill them stab them in the
back and he's like his his gaze is
supposed to be scary
that's earlier uh that's that's against
the Persians that's when Athens and
Sparta were basically on the the same
side you know
um
any other questions yeah
and played on yeah
would your thought be
the ideas and not necessarily delineate
exactly whose is which and just kind of
cover them kind of meld them together
well I mean there's some that are
clearly platonic I mentioned you know
most Scholars think that Socrates didn't
come up with the theory of the forms
um and there's there's other things too
I mean Plato
clearly believed in reincarnation which
he may have gotten from the pythagoreans
it doesn't look like Socrates likely
believed in that himself
um so we can make some delineations but
when we get to some other things it's
you know it gets
harder to say
and any position that somebody takes can
be can be questioned right and you know
how much do we really need to know what
the historical Socrates himself
taught I mean if we want to be ancient
Scholars that can be helpful but not
much rides on it you know most of the
time we're interested in what did he
mean to this particular group or
tradition because he was taken on by by
so many
um and you know the students in my my
intro classes they're just trying to
like wrap their heads around this stuff
they they don't need to like
um
have staked out a clear defensible
position I don't make them do that right
there might be some professors who do
but but I never do that yeah is there
any ancient historians
um
Plato oh yeah
story yes
um diogenese liertes is probably the
most important he wrote this this
massive thing called the lives of the
philosophers right and it's very funny
um this may sound a little mean-spirited
but
Scholars tend to trust diogenes
because they think he wasn't very smart
so he wasn't smart enough to make up
stuff
consistently you know and he does
actually now interestingly diogenes does
like to cite his sources so he'll say
sotion in this book says this about this
person and we've lost all of those right
so he's kind of a cool source for that
Aristotle is another important Source
now Aristotle is separated from Socrates
by you know decades
and but he does say a lot about Socrates
which maybe he got from Plato you know
or from other sources
he's not a historian we think of
Aristotle's a philosopher but he does
actually like talk about the historical
progression of things
um
there's there's quite a few people who
bring up Socrates later on but they're
separated from him by not decades but
like hundreds of years and so we could
be like well
where's this coming from right is there
any sort of like tradition that this
stemmed from and in most cases we just
don't know you know
um we you know we've lost
at least 70 percent of the ancient
literature that we know existed from
diogenes Laertes lives of the
philosophers like he'll give us lists of
some of the people that we're going to
talk about later he'll be like yeah
antisthenes wrote all these different
books and we don't have a single one of
them you know not even like fragments
from them
um so we're kind of at a loss I mean we
could have like a great discovery
sometime and you know there's this place
Hercule and am where they have all these
Scrolls that were part of a library and
they got burned up but they're they're
still preserved and now they're using
like x-ray technology to read them we
could find something cool
in one of those but nobody's really
holding their breath so so it's kind of
like what you see is what you get you
know but we've got we've got a good bet
you know
so well let's talk about the uh Socratic
method this is like something that
people love and to say that they're
doing most of the time that you see
somebody saying that they're doing a
Socratic method it's got very loose
connection with Socrates himself because
um you know there doesn't seem to be a
single consistent method that Socrates
practiced if you look at the various
dialogues in which he's engaged in
things he doesn't say that he has a
method a methodose you know or a single
approach and if there was such a thing
it wouldn't look like what you see
packaged by life coaches or education
experts who want to teach you the
Socratic method because oftentimes what
they
um
mean by that is something that we can
actually identify nowadays as trolling
you know uh they'll say I'm just asking
questions man I'm being like Socrates
you know I don't have any agenda anybody
who says they don't have an agenda
almost always does
um and you know they'll say that they're
only interested in uncovering the truth
so they're not you know they're not you
know prejudicing where the questions are
going to go
Socrates did a hell of a lot more than
just ask people questions and and when
he did ask people questions he did it in
a a couple different ways that are aimed
at at doing something so you know if we
look at the better literature out there
about Socratic method uh like how to do
it in the classroom or stuff like that
what we usually see is
it's uh asking questions that are aimed
at like uncovering what people's
assumptions are you know you you say
this is that because you think this
um why do you think that is the case
um that's that's an important part of it
uh we also want to like uncover what
people's values are which sometimes
they're not completely conscious of you
there's more than just asking questions
though because you have to compare
things and say oh over here you said
this and that's that's cool if that's
true but you're also saying this over
here and these aren't really compatible
so what what's going on with that which
of these do you actually prefer or do
you have some way to make sense of this
that's pretty Socratic that's that's
reflective of what he did but you know
there's other aspects as well
so one one person I saw as I was digging
around seeing what people have to say
about Socratic method he was a professor
of political science he talked about
productive discomfort and I think that's
part of the Socratic method as well you
um you're not trying to like you know
you don't put attack on somebody's seat
it's not like that or like turn the heat
up too high or turn it down but you're
asking people questions not to be a jerk
not to make them feel embarrassed for
embarrassment's sake or show them
they're stupid but to get them into
spots where they in fact do feel like oh
man I I thought I knew what I was
talking about but maybe I don't
the ancient word for that is operia
meaning literally it's like you go into
a path we call these cul-de-sacs right
you drive into it and you like in a
subdivision you're like oh crap I can't
I can't get through here you know I got
to go around the circle and come back
out and go around some other way well
that happens a lot in platonic dialogues
Socrates will talk to somebody
and they'll think that they know what
they're talking about like great example
of this is is his friend Mino
Mito says hey I give talks about virtue
you know and so actually says oh that's
cool man I I wish I knew what virtue was
because people are asking me about it
all the time could you uh could you tell
me what it is and mino's like yeah
there's Justice and wisdom and
magnanimity and courage and then
Socrates that's nice but I'm not looking
for a list what what ties all these
together I mean I was like oh okay
that's that's a good point
um how about this and they try out a
couple things and at a certain point
Mino who's you know kind of a
happy-go-lucky guy
he says to Socrates you're like a
Stingray or another it's also translated
torpedo fish this this thing that
paralyzes you you know we can get a
similar thing you ever look at nine volt
battery to test whether it works and you
get that zappy thing and your tongue
feels kind of weird
um so he's saying Socrates you do that
to my brain you know I think I know what
I'm talking about you talk with me for a
bit and then I'm just totally confused I
have no idea how to to get out of this
or which way to go and then Socrates
says hey that's okay man
that's what happens to me too
but this is an important uh part of it
right realizing what we what we actually
don't know that allows us to then be
able to say okay we gotta we gotta start
from the start we got to do something
different in this case you know because
what we've been doing so far clearly we
don't know what we're doing or talking
about if we want to make some some uh
progress we got to do things differently
and Socrates does this with you know
speakers he does this in the lock case
with a general this guy lockase who is a
successful General very brave and he's
like what is courage and a lot of cases
like
I don't know uh let's try this let's try
this and then Socrates is like well no
that doesn't work here's why uh and then
lock case at a certain point is like
I I you know I know I know what courage
is because I've exhibited it but I I
sure as hell can't tell you what it is
you know this is this is an important
part this is progress in a way
um and you know as I was talking with
one of my uh tutorial students today
about this he actually said something
really interesting
um because we were talking about
Socrates and some of these early
dialogues
and he said
um part of the Socratic method is I
understand it and this is a this is a
you know 18 year old you know guy so
this is pretty cool to have that
realization at that point also to be
interested in philosophy that young so
he said um
empathy is involved you know what you
see what I see Socrates doing is when
he's talking with these people he
genuinely wants to help them out he's
not just being a prick and you know
trying to tear people down and make them
look foolish or anything like that there
are people doing that in his society and
he's accused of doing that but really
he's he's very engaged with the people
he's talking to he cares about them he
cares about whether they figure things
out he puts the he puts himself in their
shoes and he's like well you know if if
I was seeing things the way you do
here's what I would say is that the way
that you see it he's uh he'll you know
he he calls the person as their own
witness is how it's expressed in in
certain places and I kind of think that
that's a really good realization you're
not doing the Socratic method
like Socrates if you don't actually care
to some degree about the people that
you're talking with
you know it doesn't mean you have to
like love them or they have to become
part of your family or something like
that but you actually have to like think
that they're worth talking to and it's
it's you know important for them to get
things get things at least not entirely
right but partly right and then you also
have to take what you're talking about
seriously you can't be cynical in the
modern sense and be doing the Socratic
method you have to be trying to find
some sort of actual truth and so you
know what do we do uh well think about
what Socrates does in the dialogues if
you if you've read them he brings up
examples and like says is this a good
example is this a good analogy does this
work
um he proposes theories and then tries
to test them out he asks the person
about their own history and whether what
they're doing makes sense
um
he uh tries to determine some sort of
Common Core to things you know if you
want to call that a definition you know
that's that's perfectly fine and so the
Socratic method
um seems to involve a lot of different
components the other thing is I
mentioned earlier some people construe
Socrates they take that one line I am
wise because I know that I don't know
things right so true wisdom is realizing
that you don't know anything well that's
only one line
what we see when we look at the platonic
dialogues over and over and over again
Socrates knows all sorts of things
and he actually thinks that other people
do as well like doctors for example
other Crafts People they know things
they just don't know everything and
he'll get his interlocutors to agree to
things by saying well don't we know that
this is the case
you know like for example in the uh the
meno when he's talking about doing
actions well well doesn't that mean
doing them with wisdom and Justice and
mino's like yeah of course you know
that's how you're not going to go wrong
and Socrates like cool so let's move on
from there
that's knowledge it may not be knowledge
of what the one topic is that they're
searching for what is virtue but they
know all sorts of other things along the
way so the Socratic method doesn't mean
pretending that none of us know anything
and we start from scratch every every
minute it's it's this ongoing process of
dialogue
that builds on on other things and
Compares a person's actions and life
with the things that they claim to know
or care about or value so
any let's take another pause just for a
minute
um
and then we'll talk about his his uh
influence and and
um
why he's such an important person in
philosophy any questions about like
Socratic method or the other stuff that
I had mentioned yeah
one of those things that we don't know
but we
sort of like the rumsfeldian unknown
unknowns yeah so is he trying to kind of
bring those into the other categories of
we do know and we do know it and oh you
know that yeah there are some cases
there are some cases where we want
exactly that so like for example
um attitudes towards death right so
he will say in various places like for
example in the apology he gives some bad
arguments to his friends about why him
dying is not only not a bad thing it's
going to be great because either it's a
you know long sleep which is a terrible
argument or I'm going to get to go down
to Hades and I'll ask Achilles questions
and nobody can shut me up because I'm
dead already right
um that's a very
positive position right at some points
he'll be like you know we don't know if
death is a good thing or a bad thing
and anybody who claims that they know is
full of crap I mean he doesn't say it in
those words but so why should we be so
terrified of death we're acting as if we
do know that death is
terrible right but we we don't really
know because uh we don't we don't have
any
way of proceeding you know now of course
he he undercuts that in some other
places where he's casting some deaths is
good and some deaths is bad like if
you're a really bad person you gotta go
down to Tartarus and you never get out
of there and they torture you forever
but it varies like resorting to
mythology and he's perfectly willing and
that might just be Plato too playing
around you know he's perfectly willing
to say this is a myth this is a
conjecture you know I don't actually
know so yeah there's all sorts of places
where
it's helpful for us to realize what we
don't know
it can remove anxieties
um
it can lead us to not make foolish
decisions that affect not just us but
other people you know so
I mean with the death thing imagine that
you had the mistaken belief that your
soul won't be at rest unless you get
like a really big headstone you know
like you go to cemeteries and you see
those not not just like one of those
little ones but like a big one maybe
like a statue or something right a
statue of you
and your family should spend 10 grand on
that or else uh your your ghost will be
restless and haunt them uh no that's a
weird belief to have but I'm sure
there's somebody who's had it Socrates
have come along and say you don't know
that uh and your family sure as hell
shouldn't spend all that money on this
crazy
Memorial you know uh maybe save it for
something that you could you know take a
vacation or uh uh I don't know make a
scholarship or something like that
although 10 grand isn't enough for a
scholarship these days right
um is that okay
well let's talk about his influence so
Socrates as all these friends right
friends companions whatever you want to
call them most of them are younger than
him although Credo as we saw is about
the same age
and you know the most famous of these is
of course Plato
um Plato actually writes himself in In
Absentia into a few of the dialogues but
Plato is not a character in any of the
dialogues but he is his brothers are in
there glaucon and adamantis
um and so you know the platonic school
we usually you know like in World sieve
or other history classes were like there
was Socrates and then he had a student
Plato and Plato is a great philosopher
and then he had a student Aristotle and
we like ignore all the other branches
coming off of this guy right and uh so
we you know we can definitely say yeah
the platonic school is Socratic in its
origin in many of its ideas uh no no
Socrates probably no Plato because Plato
he had other stuff to do he was rich he
was from a noble family he was a great
wrestler
um you know Plato means broad he was
like a big big hulking guy he here's
also a great poet and he abandoned that
stuff to hang out with Socrates so
Socrates clearly impressed the hell out
of him but Plato's just one of these
people right so we also have and you see
some of these on the timeline like when
they were born
um xenophon xenophon writes about
Socrates and about other stuff he
doesn't start a school but the next guy
who's kind of similar to xenophon in
some respects antistanies he does start
a school not a platonic School the cynic
School
um he he is perhaps the first cynic
there's actually some scholarly debate
about whether
you know anticipants really did start a
school or whether diogenes
um started the school but I think
there's no reason to think that
antithenes wasn't a Founder there's
another guy escanies that we don't know
that much about he apparently wrote some
dialogues of his own actually so did
antisthenese so did
um uh xenophon and Plato Fado also wrote
some
um
but we've lost them and and escanese
doesn't appear to have done much as far
as like starting a school
um Fato did though
Fato actually went to Ellis started
another Socratic school that we call the
Elian Eritrean school because it moved
around a bit and we don't know that much
about them euclidase founded this school
in megura called the magarian school you
know uh interestingly enough they had
some interesting positions they made
some contributions to philosophical
debates and discussions aristipus
another friend of Socrates actually
helped to support Socrates sending him
money he would take money for teaching
as did eskinese and send it to Socrates
and sometimes Socrates would send it
back and sometimes Socrates would keep
the money
you know Socrates is often oh you know a
real teacher doesn't take money for what
they do well yeah but you know they also
wind up being dirt poor and
impoverishing their families then like
Socrates did with his poor kids running
through his wife zanthipy's Dowry
um you know it's it's it's nice to to
have that Financial Independence but uh
every once in a while aristipus would
send him some some money and he would he
would uh according to you know the
stories take it uh we have um Credo of
course we mentioned we have this other
guy Simon the cobbler who is a student
of Socrates escanese by the way was
apparently the son of a sausage maker
which is kind of low class you know in
ancient Greece but you know not that bad
Socrates dad was a stone worker you know
he wasn't like some ruling archon or
something his mom
um eventually becomes a midwife after
his dad dies when he's about 18 or so
um so we've got all these different
people right
we know that there were way more
dialogues written than the ones that we
actually possess
um and each of these people has a kind
of story so xenophon you know we know a
lot about him because he wrote as a
historian
um he wrote some useful things about
Socrates he wrote a symposium that's
different than Plato's Symposium because
they happen to have different uh
symposia drinking parties he also
recorded his version of Socrates defense
and there's some other interesting
conversations that take place
antisthenes right from him we get the
cynic school that's an important School
we often these days don't teach about it
but it was one of the major schools of
antiquity you know they didn't have a
ton of students but they had a massive
influence they went out of favor for a
while and then they came back in uh
later on uh to the point where Julian
the apostate or Julian the emperor
actually has to write a piece called to
the uneducated cynics because there's
all these people over here that are
screwing around pretending to be cynics
and doing things wrong he's like the
real cynics are are behaving in this way
and the cynics Trace themselves back to
Socrates
they view what they're doing as in line
with a certain you know motive is
teaching
um euclides the the magarian school they
were much more into logic and dialectic
and they made some contributions
um we don't have that much from them
they don't appear to have been too
important of a school except that they
wound up feeding into as did the cynics
one of the most important schools of
later Antiquity the stoics
Zeno uh the founder of stoicism studied
with karates the cynic he studied with
stillpo the magarian he studied with
polamo from Plato's Academy brought all
these doctrines together into a new
fusion and that's where the stoic school
gets its start
aristipus founds a hedonist school you
know devoted to pleasure and he's very
much about let's get pleasure very
directly don't worry about the future
he's not like an Epicurean he's he's
very much about enjoying himself he gets
criticized for you know
frequenting prostitutes they call them
companions hatirai but they were really
you know sex workers and he's like
if I want to have sex and have that
pleasure why the hell wouldn't I do that
this is so straightforward and direct
you know there's a very famous
prostitute that he uh spends time with
named lais
and people criticize him and he's like I
have lice not she I so long as I can
like walk away from it when I want to
I'm master of my Pleasures it's not
about abstaining from Pleasures it's
about enjoying them as much as possible
and so he found he founds a whole school
devoted to that
was he influenced by Socrates I mean he
says that he learned some things from
Socrates this is not a Socratic teaching
but he is a Socratic right he is one of
his his students
um fatou I mentioned found the Ellie and
eretry in school we get the platonic
school which continues on through all
sorts of interesting permutations
Plutarch uh the great middle platonist
philosopher he will attribute all sorts
of things to Socrates actually this goes
to the the question about you know what
about these later historians so Plutarch
he will take doctrines because he's a
he's a platonist that really belonged to
Aristotle like the doctrine of the
golden mean you know in ethics it'll say
yes Socrates taught that
quite unbelievably but he's doing that
because he's on team Plato you know
um
the Aristotelian school should we
consider that a Socratic school I mean
sort of like once removed because
he is you know he's studying with
somebody who got into philosophy through
Socrates and
um you know Aristotle actually has a lot
of differences with Socrates he doesn't
like irony and we haven't talked at all
about Socratic irony but irony is in the
original sense is
um pretending that you don't know
something when you actually do and
Aristotle Socrates practice that all the
time we mentioned oh I don't I don't
know anything about wisdom why don't you
tell me all about it you know oh I don't
know how rhetoric works why don't you
explain it to me gorgeous right and
Socrates does know Aristotle thought
that that was kind of
vicious you know you should be honest
about what you actually do know but you
know he thought Socrates is okay in many
other respects
um there were a few other
schools teachers that were independent
of the socratic tradition but there's
not much in a in ancient world you've
got pyro and pyronian skepticism right
pyro does his own thing comes back but
there's also skepticism in the platonic
Academy so that's tracing itself back to
Socrates you do have the Epicurean
School the other hedonist School of
antiquity pretty important they're not
direct they're not connected with
Socrates in any way they're they're
doing their own thing and then I guess
you could say that the pythagoreans who
anti-date Socrates
you know they're not Socratic but they
get sucked into the platonic tradition
with what we know about them and then we
have rhetoric teachers like isocrates
who had his own School in in Athens
about the same time as Aristotle
not Socratic either right but also not
philosophy
um and every one of these schools is not
just
you know carrying out research or
writing things it's a way of life
Socrates imparted a certain way of life
or sets of ways of life to people and
then they kind of made of him what they
wanted to all the way down to you know
the Christian ERA with people like
Epictetus a stoic who thinks that
Socrates is you know an early stoic uh
Exemplar just like diogenes was he
thanks and Zeno and um Socrates is one
of the most mentioned people in
epictetuses discourses but he likes
Socrates he actually says
I'm never going to be a Socrates but I
can at least be a good Epictetus you
know because Socrates is viewed as this
this really great guy so Socrates
was influential enough to give rise to a
whole bunch of
different ways of living out philosophy
as a coherent intentional way of life
and and it continues on down to the
present you know I'm skipping way over
the Middle Ages where Socrates is a
virtuous Pagan and all that but if
you've ever read any existentialist
philosophy he plays a role in there
right you got Kierkegaard writing his
dissertation on the concept of irony in
Socrates drawing on Plato and xenophon
Socrates is mentioned again in
philosophical fragments he's you know
he's not everything but he's he's a
really good guy
Nietzsche hated Socrates guts he thought
that Socrates along with euripides early
on in the birth of tragedy these guys
ruined everything
uh and then later even later on he's
always poking at Socrates you know uh
he's he's a uh a bad influence you could
say Gabriel Marcel
um when Jean-Paul start essentially
defined all the other existentialists
out of existentialism with his
existentialism is a humanism other
existentialists were like well if that's
what it means that I'm not one anymore
like Heidegger writes the letter on
humanism Gabrielle Marcel starts calling
himself a Christian Socratic
why would he do that because he he
thinks that Socrates is a really
important model for how to do philosophy
you know how to question how to how to
think about things how to put together
uh accounts how to explore what Marcel
called the mystery and people even down
to today I mean we still teach them in
philosophy classes why are we doing that
because there's something about this guy
you know and the stories that are told
about him and what we can learn from his
example that is uh rather compelling and
what I would I'll end here by saying
it's interesting to see that he could
um spin off so many different not all
compatible viewpoints on him but we
could say similar things with Jesus
right I mean think about the many many
different interpretations of who this
Jesus of Nazareth fellow was you know
probably many more incompatible
interpretations than of Socrates
um or you know think about in
interpretations of the this character
that we call the Buddha you know
Siddhartha Gautama and what he was
teaching there's something about certain
um
what do you want to call them sages
World historical individuals
contributors to the realm of ideas
that gives you a kind of like a deposit
that different people draw different
things from and you know they all seem
at least to me to have some legitimacy
to them
yeah
philosophical
congratulations or more for his method
well they're they're integrated
right and it's also for taking his stand
and being willing to die for philosophy
so it's his way of life as well
um
now you know it's interesting because
you could say well
some people like if we have the
skeptical Socrates oh I don't know
anything nobody knows anything
I at least know that I don't know right
that's that's like one philosophical
Doctrine but it can lead to a way of
life right well if you don't know
anything you don't make a hell of a lot
of commitments right so yeah and then
you could have a much more
um positive Socrates over here who's
telling people you really need to get
your life in gear pay attention to your
soul not your body not your possessions
not your reputation right
um that's that's another really
important aspect of the guy you know
um
and he is you know he is uh
pretty well integrated in the culture
that he's inhabiting but he's he's
changing the culture too and so this is
you know like he's formed by his history
but he's massively contributing to the
history
uh afterwards
um I mean is it fair to say like
Whitehead did you know all philosophies
footnotes to Plato no that's that's a
ridiculous thing to say
um it's and it's not all footnotes to
Socrates either but you know he's he's
really a central character and and and
and uh what gets philosophy going as a a
discipline
um
any other questions or yeah yeah what
were his political views you know he
didn't like democracy but he also stood
up for it
um he didn't like democracy in part
because and you know Greek democracy was
much more direct than what we have and
it did tend to lead to a lot of
demagoguery right and Pericles
you know he played with that El
sobieties you know does that there's
other Democrats
um within the you know well although
this war is going on who um like crayon
who were demagogues as well and they
would they would do things he also
didn't like the fact that like
in democracies you can make dumb
decisions quick right by the people get
mad you know there's actually a case
where these generals are being tried
uh contrary to the the legal rules and
everyone else is like yeah these guys
they're responsible for the military
defeat let's kill these bastards right
and Socrates is like whoa whoa uh we
have rules here don't we and they're all
like shut up Socrates uh I mean I'm
kind of being facetious here but uh he
he thought it was important to like if
you've got Norms you need to follow them
and democracy was kind of bad that way
uh on the other hand he didn't really
like
um the oligarchical uh cities either and
he was he was fine you know people were
like well if you like if you don't like
Athens why don't you go to Sparta and
he's like no no I'm fine here it happens
you know this is my city
um so yeah he did have quite a few
political views I mean you could say
that his basic political view is
things are going to be screwed up so
long as we trust people who think that
they know what they're doing and don't
really know what they're doing which is
almost uniformly the case
and this is part of how he got himself
killed he would go around and he would
question you know so there's this famous
incident right I should probably just in
case anybody doesn't know this a friend
of his a real smart ass named kyrophon
goes to Delphi and he has the
opportunity to ask the Oracle anything
he wants right and so he wastes his
Oracle question on is Socrates is there
anyone wiser than Socrates which is not
the same thing as is Socrates the wisest
and the Oracle just says no and so then
he comes back to Socrates he's like you
never guess what the Oracle told me
you're the wisest guy in in uh in Greece
and Socrates is like where the hell are
you getting that from well here's here's
what the Oracle said so Socrates is like
that can't be right you know I mean the
God can't lie but I got to figure out
what the hell Apollo means so let me go
to people who actually are wise or at
least say they're wise I think they're
wise and uh I'll disprove the god
so I go to this politician and I ask him
some questions and it turns out this guy
doesn't actually know what he's talking
about you know he's full of crap and
then you know that guy gets mad because
he's embarrassed at being shown up by
this you know bald ugly guy Socrates and
then he's like well I'll ask the next
guy and he just goes down the line you
know and none of them know anything and
so hassock says well I'm a little bit
better off now I know I don't have to
worry about the politicians but he does
have to worry about him because all of
them hate his guts now right so so
um his his uh activity got him a lot of
enmity
and there's actually there's a funny
place in the Mino where there's one of
his actual accusers
shows up and Socrates and minor are
having this discussion about like well
who actually can teach virtue who who
you know Pericles his kids turned out
bad I guess Pericles didn't know what
real virtue was and anitas says you
better watch out Socrates talking like
that can get you in real trouble here
you know and it's like foreshadowing the
fact that they are going to put him on
trial for that but you know if Athens
hadn't gone through all these
catastrophes maybe they wouldn't have
done that maybe there was some
scapegoating involved you know it's a
way of discharging some bad feelings so
you had your hand up yeah
it makes us the whole metaphysics heavy
stuff seems to be probably more likely
yeah yeah
so if another way to eliminate might be
uh the parts or maybe dialogues as a
whole where stock juice is really a not
liked guy but I at least one or more
antagonists
um like so we have technology where I
guess the council be like the antagonist
and then we might have like the Republic
where thrustmakis is kind of an
antagonist and really doesn't like him a
lot or seems really mad at him anyway
yeah at the start
because because thrasymnica sticks
around and in book six through semicus
is like no no go on I want to hear this
stuff right so he converts him yeah so
he so you want to say dialogues where
there's enmity or
um
you know Discord those would be the more
platonic ones and then I mean the
apology doesn't work right because we
know that's that's pretty success
Democratic oh okay
that's interesting you know because uh
one of the ones that comes to mind for
me right away is the gorgeous
um
but it's it's kind of understandable so
in the gorgeous right gorgeous is this
great Rudder and he has come to town and
Socrates whenever somebody famous comes
to town he's always like I gotta go talk
to this guy right so he goes to
calekly's house and calacles is a rich
guy he's almost like a salon holder type
of person you know and so gorgeous is
there gorgeous is uh younger Protege
polis is there and then you know so
Socrates questions gorgeous and that's
pretty cordial you know and Socrates
basically shows that gorgeous doesn't
know anything other than how to teach
people rhetoric he doesn't know whether
rhetoric is good or bad or stuff like
that then polis gets in and he starts to
get more antagonistic and then it gets
really antagonistic with
um the final thing with calacles who's
kind of like thrasymichus and Socrates
but it makes sense Socrates is being a
jerk he's a bad guest with
it's calikly's house he doesn't expect
somebody to come in and like be show his
guests you know that they don't know
what they're talking about or stuff like
that and um
you know so by that that would mean that
that would be more platonic more
Socratic than platonic
um maybe
um
yeah I mean
there's others where there's there it
gets pretty antagonistic where he's
talking with particular sophists
[Music]
but I don't know
it could be that
that conflict
um
there's probably plenty of it in what we
consider to be later dialogues as well
it all depends on how we parse the
conflict too right so
like in the gorgeous calicles actually
says to Socrates don't get don't get mad
Socrates don't don't have Orga anger
which is a weird thing because Socrates
isn't getting bad but it's sort of like
on online discourse where people they
accuse other people of getting mad and
then they've won the debate you know I
think maybe there's a little bit of that
going on in that but yeah there's we
could have multiple lenses for trying to
differentiate them and I think that the
best we can do is have like definitely
platonic definitely Socratic
um depends on how we look at it kind of
in the middle you know are there any
medical heavy ones that are really
antagonistic or haven't really
antagonistic character I don't haven't
read anything that's a
no that's that's more like hey let's
expand this whole story of creation some
of the dialogues are much less
dialogical too you know
um
I mean there's the parmedides which
begins with Parmenides meeting a young
Socrates
you know Socrates
um believing in but not quite
understanding a theory of form so that
we think this is a platonic and
permanentes raising problems with the
theory of forms and then going into this
crazy dialectic for the rest of the
thing where you're like what the hell is
this about what what's going on here is
this like did Plato just write a logical
exercise that his students had to run
through or something and there's various
theories about it but they're all
I've always found them kind of
implausible I don't think we we do know
why
but yeah other other later dialogues
where there is a lot of conflict
um
nothing comes to mind but
you know it for some of them it's been
years since I've read them
so I don't know
that is an interesting idea though
but maybe not
yeah if we think about why there's
conflict it's usually because people get
they feel defensive or threatened or
they don't like
um Socrates showing that they don't that
either they don't know what they're
doing or that the people that they look
to don't know what they're doing so yeah
but in the Socrates is kind of a jerk in
some respects right he goes into
agathon's place and makes makes agathon
look foolish at zagathan's house you
know it's not it's not good behavior uh
and I think a lot of times people cut
Socrates way more slack than they should
you know but I'm probably in the
minority I'm saying that because he
often gets held up as like this great
hero right so
any other questions or
they're gonna they're gonna ring the oh
we gotta get out of here pretty soon but
anything else you want to know about or
comes to mind or
impact on any of this kind of historical
no
um
I mean
well then he has the last laugh right
because he by looking at the sky he
predicts the bumper crop of Olives buys
up very shrewdly the olive presses and
then charges everybody what he wants and
makes a million or something you know
phallus like Nietzsche for example will
say thales is the first real philosopher
not because he comes first but because
he said everything is something you know
so like it's there's a metaphysical
Viewpoint there you know
um Aristotle talks about him because
Aristotle is like into you know who did
what first and and why their account was
deficient and why my account you know
does all the things that nobody else was
able to fully do so phallus is really
early on and the the physicist thing
um Socrates doesn't talk much about him
um
it's interesting because the person he
brings up the most is an exaggerus right
and an exaggerus he was one of the ones
we almost got in trouble in Athens uh
because the annexaggers said stuff like
you know the sun is a stone so is the
moon you know these aren't like gods or
stuff like that and a lot of people
didn't like hearing that
but apparently Pericles
um was connected with the anax in some
way and Socrates read some of an
exaggerus's uh Scrolls in his books
looking for answers to everything and
then he's like well this isn't very good
at all you know it doesn't answer the
questions that I actually have
so I mean Socrates didn't make much of
these physicist people and pedicles and
exaggeras
the other everything is this or that
kind of guys I mean you know Plato is
really interested in the contrast
between heraclitus
and permanentes right but we don't know
that Socrates himself was that into them
you know that might be more platonic
stuff right because that's that's the
heavy metaphysics you know so yeah
any other questions
things you want to know more about or
all right well thanks so much for
another great session and for your
questions and comments and hopefully uh
you know now you know a bit more about
this guy's Socrates and his place in
history and
um we'll do we'll do another
um the next one coming up is on
Bonaventure in May and then we've got
um further sessions in August and
November but I don't remember exactly
who we're doing for those is it on there
oh thanks yeah I mean I I should
actually know shouldn't I oh yeah David
Hume yeah uh for some reason I thought I
was doing Mary woolstone craft but
apparently I'm not so yeah David Hume
that's going to be fun and then Iris
Murdoch if you don't know her stuff
she's a novelist as well as a
philosopher from the 20th century great
novels
um really interesting philosophical work
um so she actually got to give the
Gifford lectures uh which is kind of
like you know that's how you know you
really made it in philosophy they invite
you to give the Gifford lectures
um and uh it's um metaphysics is a guide
to morals is is that really interesting
stuff so so we'll talk about those I
hope you can join me for for more of
these and um yeah thanks for
for your uh contributions and we'll pick
it up again next time